well that was the best episode of the
season like not even
by slightly i mean a clear mile best
episode of the season it had everything
really had a lot of flavors in here you
know you had your infiltration mission
interesting character moments you had
your backstory reveals that we're tied
into interesting character moments it's
a good episode so our crew goes to this
facility where
they find out that vot has a whole
scheme a whole plan
going with giving adults super powers
with compound v
and homelander and stormfront they're
banging in an alley after he smashes a
dude's head
which i gotta say some of you out there
you are twisted people
i mean [ __ ] love your style we're all
twisted right we're all kind of messed
up but after last week's episode i
started seeing theories that stormfront
was homelanders mom i'll say that again
after last week's episode so after
stormfront and homelander
[ __ ] and people were like what if she's
his mom
only after bless you twisted humans and
your messed up theories part of what i
liked about this episode is
you have your infiltration mission they
go into this facility where lamplighter
is working
basically as an orderly orderly slash
incinerator
which is funny sean ashmore who was
iceman in the x-men movies his nemesis
was
pyro and now in the boys he essentially
is pyro is him being in this episode is
that going to tie into the past and you
know he burned those kids and that lady
was like
bird watching yeah that was very jumbled
i love it when i can be that jumbled my
thoughts can be that sparse and so
poorly explained and if you've seen
season one you're like
i know what he's saying though but okay
there's this soup in this facility
that pops people like water balloons
because the force
of course didn't mean for that to rhyme
that was
cheesy unintentionally so point is sith
never do that in star wars and i just
don't know why but then
super magneto sith soup breaks down all
the doors and
releases all the other super people
they're making super people
and so it's people with like they vomit
acid
or you know they have the force they can
make things float they have a huge dick
i just thought he had a huge dick and
then you see the monitor
and it kind of looks like the end of
cabin in the woods
which kind of cracked me up you see this
tentacle dragging people around i'm like
tentacle
thought nothing of it then when the
tentacle grabbed mother's milk by the
neck i had this philosophical thought
which i was like
is that the dick you gotta love the fact
this shows like
we're gonna have a dick that strangles
people
cause we're the boys but there's some
solid character tension in here you see
some flashback with
frenchie lamplighter because he was
their informant like i knew that
he killed kids and that just caused the
band to break up but i didn't know that
he was like
their guy on the inside and that shows
why butcher doesn't like starlight at
all he's like
i've been here working with no but he
and starlight have some bonding moments
in here which seem kind of forced
doesn't matter though cause huey got
hurt and we all band together for huey
kiwi got impaled when that dude just
blasted the van and they were like
we need to go to the hospital probably
not smart though since they're all like
really wanted people i don't know how
the cops aren't there the feds
i don't know why they're not there right
now you go to a vet like any good
criminal so as much as season one built
you to like hate this guy
in the end you're like oh you're another
tragedy
of vaught i'm not saying he's a rose
he's not a peach
by any means but you just get the
feeling vaught
it's just a super evil thing that leaves
devastation and [ __ ] up people in its
wake
you're either a complete and total [ __ ]
bag
or you're damaged like there's no in
between i mean for a while we've kind of
felt like queen maeve
is a good person but she's just in too
deep she's trying to dig her way out now
because someone had a gopro on that
flight i love the fact that that
clearly businessman dad was like
i'm gonna have a gopro because you never
know when youtube is gonna call me why
was he using a gopro though like was he
gonna do extreme sports on his vacation
like why didn't he use his phone
then again to be fair uh he seems like
the kind of guy who
has a blackberry from 2008. so hey maybe
there's that i got an intention there
what was my thought oh yeah good people
shitty situations but yeah you just feel
like
maeve is that person you know she was
probably like brought in and all the
glitz and glamours like
she's the endgame of starlight we got
that in season one starlight was like
don i'm gonna go this way so even with
lamplighter this person who burned kids
you're like oh clearly he's a scumbag
and yeah he went there to kill the lady
that butcher and all them were working
with
just so you get the feeling he's torched
people before it's his mo it's this
thing it's a show
that's really built around pr i don't
know how people are like
dude has a torch and burns things
clearly a hero that's not a villain
power at all
what did they think he did did they
think they were like lamplighter we need
to get through that wooden door
do you mind homelanders here clearly you
can just
breathe on it and it'll cave in but now
we need you like
what did they think they did with that
huge oversized
lamp thing but the point is i bought it
when he was sitting there and this lady
is like i'm gonna kill him
you get the fact he's like i do want you
to and
frenchy the voice of logic and reason is
like
you'll just end his suffering it is true
it's like there's nothing you can do to
this guy that he hasn't already done to
himself
this guy has beaten himself up beyond
repair
for that thing because he didn't mean to
kill kids
but he did and so in an angle a twist a
turn an event
that i didn't see coming lamplighters
part of the crew now
gotta stay in a world where i just love
surprises that was a surprise and then
stormfront revealed to homelander after
he was
just raging out because he's the jealous
boyfriend
type she's like hey by the way i'm super
old and
nazis gave me my fib well vaught dead
but working with nazis apparently which
i had heard was the case with stormfront
in the graphic novel and in the end
super magneto sith soup i don't know why
i keep saying magnetos because you know
rip the metal doors down but the force
can do that too so
sith point is gets away retire on a
beach maybe
go into vaught to burn that [ __ ] down
possibly
we shall see which is interesting
because the character's name is actually
cindy and last we saw
cindy cindy gets fried gets shocked by
storm front then the next time we see
cindy
hitchhiking on the road but i feel like
there is a chunk of dialogue
there's a situation missing purposely so
do they have the walter white hector
salamanca speech you know where it's
like
you don't like me but i'm willing to bet
there's someone you hate more
and they're gonna unleash sinned on the
storm front don't know but i do think
that character is
a piece of the plan but in the end great
episode maybe it's because i have a soft
spot for those episodes of television
that give you the flashback reveals
which is why my favorite episode of
season one of heroes was the episode
called company man i believe it was
episode 17 of season one so good but
yeah it all worked together for me to be
like
best episode of the season so far hey
maybe season two was one of those
slow start but great payoff kind of
season but alright the boys season two
episode
six have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know only two episodes left
time
does fly and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you